bonsoir aujourd'hui lundi 1er décembre
nouvelle semaine pour le journal de la
rédaction sur TVfil il est 18h si vous
nous suivez en direct et dans
l'actualité la mobilisation contre le
sida nouvelle journée annuelle de lutte
pour les associations qui rappellent
notamment que deux jeunes sont touchés
chaque jour par la maladie parmi les
étudiants français ils ne sont que 33% à
utiliser systématiquement un préservatif
lors d'un rapport sexuel Nicolas Sarkozy
élu président de l'UMP et après les
attentes de ces partisans avec Daniel
bozinski responsable du comité de
soutien génération elle Sarkozy 78 il
est l'invité de ce journal vous
entendrez aussi la réaction du président
du Sénat livlinois Gérard Larcher ils
étaient dans les rues à Paris ce matin
aux côtés des patrons les entrepreneurs
du bâtiment comme les autres chefs
d'entreprise dénoncent salariale trop
élevée complications administrative ou
encore la difficulté à embaucher
plus de 30 ans après sa découverte le
VIH résiste toujours au médecin le virus
de l'imuno déficience humaine
responsable du sida le syndrome
d'immunodéficience acquise tue toujours
pas de vaccins pas de thérapie mais
néanmoins des avancées pour prolonger la
durée de vie des malades mais au prix de
lourdes effets secondaires nous sommes
en ligne avec Jérôme André bonsoir
directeur de HF prévention basé dans les
Yvelines vous intervenez pour
sensibiliser les populations cette
journée de mobilisation du 1er décembre
quel message doit-on faire passer celui
de l'espoir grâce aux avancées médicales
ou encore le message de la vigilance en
raison du nombre de malades 35 millions
de par le monde en 2013 c'est autant
qu'en 2012 ça n'évolue pas beaucoup
alors malheureusement Wilfried
effectivement ce qu'on peut en dire des
derniers chiffres d'invs qui étaient
sous embargo donc jusqu'à midi c'est
qu'effectivement il y a une flambée de
la contamination donc sur 2013 plus de
7% en plus de cas de personnes
séropositives ça n'était pas arrivé
depuis 10 ans donc effectivement on se
rend bien compte aujourd'hui en France
que la télé est en train de repartir et
donc et plus que jamais de la ministre
appel à plus de prévention et plus de
dépistage puisqu'on sait effectivement
que le dépistage et la prévention sont
vraiment les deux piliers de la santé
publique aujourd'hui puisque vous parlez
de chiffres aussi celui-ci et qui va
aller dans le sens de ce que vous nous
expliquez deux étudiants sur trois 67%
qui n'utilisent pas systématiquement de
préservatif pour un rapport sexuel et
même un étudiant sur trois qui n'utilise
jamais c'est une enquête qui a été menée
par une mutuelle étudiante la SMEREP là
on est dans le coeur de votre mission
c'est la prévention il va falloir
retourner encore plus sur le terrain et
expliquer les dangers tout simplement
alors effectivement nous notre cœur de
métier c'est la prévention et le
dépistage on a sorti donc en juin
dernier ça a été lancé donc mardi
dernier sur TF1 la grande campagne de
communication pour promotionner
l'application pub qui justement permet
de trouver donc et de se le géolocaliser
pour trouver des préservatifs mais aussi
donc des lieux de dépistage parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte
qu'il est plus que nécessaire de pouvoir
connaître son statut sérologique les
chiffres sont d'environ 30 000 personnes
qui s'ignorent mais on pense que c'est
beaucoup plus en réalité effectivement
sur les milieux ouverts ciblés
c'est-à-dire les universités les centres
commerciaux en 2014 on n'a pas encore
vraiment les chiffres définitifs mais on
serait à plus de 2% c'est à dire quand
même 0,8 de plus que l'année dernière et
on se rend bien compte que chez les
jeunes et la synérès a complètement
raison il s'est enfin le préservatif est
complètement abandonné alors justement
on voit la publicité qui est diffusée
sur les différentes chaînes nationales
notamment TP trouver un préservatif
c'est une application disponible sur
tous les smartphones les accès sont il y
a le site internet l'adresse là aussi et
c'est affichée on parlait de cette
sensibilisation sur le terrain les
jeunes que vous rencontrez tout au long
de l'année il vous passe quel message
que vous les embêtez finalement avec
cette maladie du siècle dernier non en
réalité il se trompent pas bien compte
de l'enjeu donc qui est le port du
préservatif pour eux effectivement ça ne
concerne que les homosexuels et les
toxicomanes alors ils sont pas forcément
homosexuels ils sont pas forcément
toxicoman et pourtant ils sont ils sont
donc concernés par les quatre
contaminations et on se rend bien compte
aujourd'hui que le la prévention est
plus particulièrement le port du
préservatif devrait concerner tout le
monde là on est dans la journée mondiale
de lutte contre le sida l'ONU
souhaiterait donc l'ONU sida
souhaiterait qu'il y ait zéro
contamination donc c'est l'objectif
c'est l'objectif donc mondial mais on se
rend bien compte que en réalité il faut
vraiment que les gens se protègent
beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
conscience qu'autre le sida et aussi
toutes les infections sexuellement
transmissibles vous parliez déjà d'en
parler des jeunes depuis tout à l'heure
il y a aussi les populations seniors et
là on en parle peut-être moins encore
les plus de 50 ans qui sont aussi
infectés par ce VIH c'est en
augmentation 18% voilà 18% sur quelques
6400 personnes qui ont découvert leur
positivité ça c'est pour 2012 ils
étaient seulement 12% en 2003 donc ça
progresse chaque année là aussi il faut
aller leur expliquer que c'est pas une
maladie qui concerne les plus jeunes
effectivement en fait en réalité nous on
parle plutôt des plus de 45 ans à la
ligne se parle de plus de 50 mais en
réalité plus les plus de 45 ans change
de comportement sexuel et c'est pas rare
on parle simplement de divorce on parle
de personnes qui vont effectivement
trouver donc ce qu'on appelle donc le
fait d'avoir des multi partenaires et
donc 45 ans c'est une période charnière
dans la tête des Français parce
qu'effectivement ils vont changer de
comportement sexuel et c'est là aussi où
il y a le plus de cas de contamination
nous on réfléchit justement à mettre en
place des actions spécifiques pour les
plus de 45 ans je rappelle aussi donc
vous l'avez dit que mais vous intervenez
pour le dépistage avec les tests minutes
on parle d'autotest pour juillet 2015
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
alors ce sera plutôt mars en réalité
donc on fait partie du groupe qui qui
lancent les autotests en France en
réalité donc il ne manque plus que le
marquage CE c'est une volonté de la
ministre et effectivement les les
autotests VIH donc qui sont sortis dans
la gamme des autotests santé sortiront
au mois de mars prochain dès que le
marquage CE aura lieu effectivement il y
aura donc un grand lancement qui sera
effectué et je l'espère d'ailleurs avec
un nouveau jeu interactif et ludique
qu'on va peut-être l'occasion de
présenter d'ailleurs sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en tout cas on
l'espère et c'est vrai que pour le coup
ça va quand même marquer un grand
tournant dans le domaine de la santé
puisque les gens vont pouvoir se tester
chez eux donc faire du Home test ils
vont pouvoir donc se tester directement
chez eux et connaître le résultat alors
ça pose donc d'autres problématiques
bien entendu mais on sera ravi de vous
présenter donc ces auto tests en réel
mais vous serez bienvenus sur ce plateau
une toute dernière question vous étiez
ce matin avec des médecins à l'hôpital
Henri Mondor à Créteil pour une
conférence de presse autour de cette
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
l'idée d'un vaccin aujourd'hui et plus
que toujours d'actualité
alors c'est très compliqué parce qu'en
réalité on se rend compte que la
recherche vaccinale a du mal à
progresser le virus malheureusement mute
beaucoup trop vite par rapport donc à la
recherche qui est quand même une
recherche longue on a tous espoir
effectivement qui est un vaccin dans
quelques années mais malheureusement
pour l'instant ce n'est pas du tout
aléte du jour et ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
à l'ordre du jour c'est plutôt des
comptes des quatre contaminations qui
sont en pleine flambée nous on avait à
insérer la sonnette d'alarme à plusieurs
reprises l'année dernière et bien
effectivement donc ça montre bien que
les câbles de contamination sont
recrudescence il faut imaginer
qu'effectivement il y a plusieurs
positifs qui ont été trouvés l'année
dernière notamment grâce au test rapide
que l'on fait mais que d'autres
associations font et c'est vrai que pour
le coup c'est vraiment nécessaire que
les gens se testent et connaissent leur
satisfaire en logique donc le plus
simple encore aujourd'hui c'est
d'utiliser un préservatif le message une
fois de plus il faut le répéter merci
Jérôme André d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous journée de lutte contre le sida
chaque premier décembre pour contacter
HF prévention les coordonnées qui
s'affichent une nouvelle fois on
n'oublie pas également cette application
trouver un préservatif ou un centre de
dépistage application à télécharger sur
vos smartphones on parle à présent de
l'actualité politique avec l'élection de
Nicolas Sarkozy ce week-end à la
présidence de l'UMP l'ancien chef de
l'État reprend à la tête de sa famille
politique qui a faim de voir ce
qu'attendre les sympathisants avec
Daniel bonzinski responsable dans les
Yvelines du groupe génération Sarkozy ce
sera dans un instant en plateau
auparavant-retour sur le scrutin avec
Mélanie poquet pour la rédaction de
tvfils depuis Elancourt ou un bureau de
vote avait été installé pour les
militants UMP ce week-end
problème de connexion problème de code
le système de vote décidé par l'UMP a
connu quelques couacs mais rien de
décourageant pour ses militants venus
pour élire leur président même pas les
cyberattaques dont a été victime le site
du parti je trouve ça lamentable c'est
ce piratage informatique et nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup insisté pour arriver à
voter aujourd'hui il a fallu nous
venions ici à la mairie à la mairie
d'Élancourt on n'avait pas prévu les
grands moyens l'élection pouvant se
faire sur internet un ordinateur
suffisait dans cette circonscription 398
militants étaient inscrits 31 on fait le
déplacement il est indispensable d'être
adhérent un jour de ses cotisations et
on ne peut voter que à cette condition
c'est on n'a pas adhéré évidemment
en temps et en heure on ne peut pas
voter aujourd'hui
chaque militant a ainsi reçu un
identifiant un mot de passe et sa carte
d'adhérent en lice 3 candidats Nicolas
Sarkozy Bruno Le Maire et Hervé Mariton
dans ce bureau de vote le choix est vite
fait Nicolas Sarkozy
Nicolas Sarkozy avec 64,5 % des voix
Nicolas Sarkozy a été élu à la tête du
principal parti d'opposition
bonsoir Daniel mozinski bonsoir de
génération Sarkozy dans les Yvelines
associations fondées par les jeunes
militants pendant cette campagne pour la
présidence de l'UMP campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy vous êtes aussi le maire adjoint
à Fontenay-le-Fleury on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur votre engagement d'ailleurs
déjà sur cette victoire on entend dire
depuis hier qu'avec 64% des voix Nicolas
Sarkozy mais finalement pas le gagnant
qu'on attendait son score il y a 10 ans
même scrutin c'était 85% alors il a
gagné est-ce que c'est un beau vainqueur
mais bien sûr que c'est un beau
vainqueur il faut surtout se souvenir
qu'avant c'était un contexte tout à fait
différent alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on
constate c'est que c'est le leader
incontesté maintenant il n'y a pas eu de
contestation de ce scrutin là c'est un
score clair qui est très important deux
militants sur 3 ont voté pour Nicolas
Sarkozy donc quand on regarde deux ans
en arrière et qui a eu toutes ces
contestations et un chef qui n'était
finalement pas clair aujourd'hui on a un
vrai leader c'est Nicolas Sarkozy on
avait annoncé un raz-de-marée mais il y
a également il y a eu il y a eu des
concurrents de qualité qui était br ma
mère et Hervé Marie Bruno Le Maire
autour de 30%, ça représente quoi pour
le pour l'UMP ça veut dire qu'il faut
compter avec lui bien sûr qu'il faut
compter avec lui puisqu'il faut compter
avec toutes les sensibilités différentes
à l'UMP Bruno Le Maire a fait une très
bonne campagne il faut la saluer il faut
aussi saluer son score et je pense que
Nicolas Sarkozy aura à cœur de
d'intégrer Bruno Le Maire pleinement à
la vie du parti dans la mesure de ce que
Bruno Le Maire se traitera Nicolas
Sarkozy qui dès aujourd'hui a consulté
pour organiser le parti est-ce qu'il est
déjà en train de préparer ses armes pour
alors
évidemment nous c'est ce qu'on souhaite
nous on a on a soutenu Nicolas Sarkozy
pour pour cette primaire on était à fond
dedans maintenant évidemment les
objectifs il y a 2017 mais avant ça il
faut surtout rappeler que Nicolas
Sarkozy il est revenu pour restructurer
l'UMP restructurer le parti et relancer
la dynamique pour toutes les élections
qu'il y aura d'ici 2017 et qui sont
également importantes et les Cantona il
y a les régionales avec Valérie Pécresse
ce sont autant de batailles à mener qui
sont sur lesquels il faut d'abord se
concentrer avant 2017 donc le
département ce sera l'année prochaine en
mars les régionales également on met en
fin d'année en décembre et Valérie
Pécresse qui est candidate pour qu'il
devrait être candidate officiellement
pour l'UMP pour pour la région
Île-de-France première mission c'est de
fédérer c'est de rassembler vous le
disiez pour Nicolas Sarkozy ça commence
plutôt mal il annonce la création d'un
cabinet d'ancien Premier ministre et
puis finalement lui dit non c'est pas
une bonne idée et principaux concernés
il a effectivement il a effectivement
proposé ça il a même proposé à Dominique
de Villepin c'est dire je vous fais pas
de bêtises qui lui était d'accord ça
prouve bien les esprit d'ouverture de
Nicolas Sarkozy derrière les mots il y a
eu des actes mais là aussi dans l'esprit
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est un parti libre
donc si ce comité
ne trouvera pas les volontaires
nécessaires il n'aura pas il n'aura il
ne verra pas le jour et puis je pense
pas que ce soit un drame ça va être
difficile de fédérer si quand on a des
idées qui sont proposées moins de 24
heures après non écoutez moi je pense
que
ce qu'il faut faire maintenant c'est
rassembler autour de Nicolas Sarkozy
toutes les différentes sensibilites à
l'UMP pour ça il faut tout simplement
nous concentrer pas sur ce qui nous
divise mais sur ce qui nous rassemble
c'est à dire les valeurs qu'on défend la
justice le travail l'Europe le parti des
droits et des devoirs tout ça ce sont
des choses qui nous rassemblent et puis
ce qui nous rassemblent aussi c'est de
sortir le gouvernement socialiste faut
être clair et de reconquérir nos
territoires un à un pour sortir les
Français de la catastrophe dans laquelle
ils sont actuellement et reconquérir la
présidence de la République il y avait
un sondage dans le JD dès ce week-end
40% des Français qui voient Alain Juppé
remporter la présidentielle de 2017 25%
pour le nouveau président de l'UMP oui
bah écoutez il peut se passer beaucoup
de choses en 2000 en 2017 pour 2012
aussi il y avait des sondages qui
disaient plein de choses et puis
finalement ça n'a pas été ce qui était
annoncé donc voilà je donne
personnellement assez peu de valeur
assez sondages là même si vous donnez
pas de valeur au sondage vous êtes allés
voir des électeurs même au-delà de l'UMP
nous sommes allés voir les citoyens tout
simplement dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour leur
demander leur avis sur ce retour à la
présidence de l'UMP de Nicolas Sarkozy
ah bah c'est un combattant c'est plutôt
bien moi je trouve finalement
c'est pas plus mal que les autres
surpris quand même parce que quand même
il a pas mal de casseroles comme on dit
ça va être temps que qu'on lui fasse
encore confiance dans son propre camp
mais je pense que c'est une bonne chose
pour lui MP contenu de la situation
pendant laquelle on a été pendant
des quelques mois depuis décembre 2012
le dernier de la dernière tentative
d'élection c'est une catastrophe donc
j'espère que qui va réussir et tout ce
que je peux dire c'était prévisible les
Français sont couillons donc ils
continuent leur lancer je sais pas les
Français ils veulent pas du renouveau
donc voilà on s'enfonce encore un coup
il faut des jeunes on fait un
franchement la France elle vieillit à
vue d'oeil et personne s'en aperçoit
c'est une catastrophe si c'est si moi je
trouve que c'est grave
de lui MP reste présentant de génération
Sarkozy dans le département vous avez
Bondy quand vous avez parce que
alors là aussi je trouve ça un peu
ridicule que un candidat puisse
s'accaparer le renouveau il faut savoir
que Nicolas Sarkozy il a non seulement
l'expérience de la France et de la
politique et il pèse sur la scène
internationale comme nationale mais il y
a le renouveau avec Nicolas Sarkozy il
faut voir de qui l'entourer voilà les
quadra Wauquiez NKM Gérald Darmanin tout
ça ce sont de nouveau visage qui qui
sont de très beaux espoirs à l'UMP il
faut comprendre de la part de la
personne qui répondait c'est aussi voilà
Nicolas Sarkozy a déjà été Président il
s'est déjà présenté une deuxième fois il
a été battu façon autre chose et oui il
y a ça mais ce que je voulais terminer
aussi c'est que génération Sarkozy dont
je suis responsable pour les Yvelines là
aussi c'est une force énorme qui a
soutenu Nicolas Sarkozy parce que c'est
avec Nicolas Sarkozy que beaucoup de
jeunes se sont engagés en politique ça a
été la locomotive et on a envie de
continuer avec cette locomotive qui est
Nicolas Sarkozy il est le renouveau avec
l'équipe dont ils s'entourent et il a
envie aussi d'apporter des idées neuves
le fait qu'il a été chef de l'État je ne
vois pas en quoi ça l'empêche d'apporter
des idées neuves de renouveler le parti
et de renouveler la façon dont il fait
la politique ce qu'il a envie de faire
des amis quel âge lorsqu'il était
président
en politique oui donc moi j'avais
j'étais au début de mes 20 ans j'avais
la vingtaine et vous n'étiez pas engagé
en politique avant Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2007 quand je venais juste de passer
mon bac et Nicolas Sarkozy ça a été le
premier à me donner envie demain
investir vraiment dans un parti et c'est
là que j'ai pris ma carte aujourd'hui
avec Génération Sarkozy justement vous
l'avez soutenu à travers toute la France
pas uniquement dans les Yvelines vous
attendez quoi maintenant que l'élection
est passée et au-delà voilà c'est ces
affaires d'homme entre Alain Juppé
François Fillon Nicolas Sarkozy mettons
tout ça de côté vous attendez quoi comme
idée alors la première chose c'est je
pense redonner confiance aux militants
je trouve que ça serait trop dommage de
gâcher
l'exercice démocratique qui a eu lieu ce
week-end il faut faire la transparence
sur les sur les fonds du parti sur les
situations financière il faut également
redonner l'implication des militants
dans la vie du parti ce qui a envie de
faire Nicolas Sarkozy il y a une
deuxième chose c'est redonner une ligne
politique claire aussi à l'UMP qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec le Centre voilà on a eu
cet épisode malheureux avec Alain Juppé
mais ça montre aussi quelque chose ça
montre une attente des mython MP qui
veulent qu'on soit fier de nos valeurs
avec une ligne politique claire la
troisième chose donc dont moi je
voudrais parler en tant que responsable
jeune à l'UMP c'est de refonder la
structure des Jeunes UMP parce
qu'aujourd'hui ben on n'a pas de on a
pas de
gouvernance claire dans cette structure
là or c'est très important parce que ça
représente beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
militants on a besoin de formation et
puis la quatrième chose c'est de
moderniser le parti il faut comme je
disais Nicolas Sarkozy intégrer la
société civile dans le parti il faut
aussi refaire l'équipe dirigeante voilà
faut dire les choses aussi il faut pas
se cacher se débarrasser de l'armée
mexicaine dont on a hérité après la
guerre copéfillon voilà on a multitude
de secrétaire nationaux je pense que
c'est plus efficace d'avoir une équipe
plus resserrée et je pense que c'est
j'ai cru comprendre que ce soit à quoi
travailler Nicolas Sarkozy actuellement
Wauquiez qui disait sur France Info il
faut tout changer le MP est un parti
poussiéreux
mais il a pas tort il a pas tort c'est
vrai que
je pense que ça fera pas de mal en tout
cas il faut changer l'intérieur aussi
bah oui c'est ce que je disais c'est à
dire voilà refonder le moderniser mais
changer de nom changer de logo tout ça
ça donnera une nouvelle dynamique j'ai
entendu dire que ça devrait se faire
avant les départementales je trouve que
c'est une chose très bien parce que ça
pourra nous faire un premier test
comment comment est-ce qu'on arbore nos
nouvelles couleurs dans une élection
qu'en pense Gérard Larcher lui c'est un
senior un poids lourd de la politique à
l'UMP j'ai remarché président du Sénat
sénateur des Yvelines il recevait la
presse ce matin nous avons profité pour
nous en avons profité pour lui poser la
question
tout d'abord nous avons un président à
l'UMP choisit clairement par un score
qui est un bon score en même temps Bruno
Le Maire fait un score lui aussi
significatif Hervé Mariton traduit une
sensibilité qui existe à l'intérieur du
MP aujourd'hui il faut construire la
priorité c'est de construire un projet
le projet pour la France d'aujourd'hui
une France qui n'a plus de croissance
une France sous le chômage est devenu de
masse où chaque mois on a entre 20 000
et 30000 chômeurs de plus une France qui
doute une France qui est à la traîne en
Europe c'est les réponses qu'il faut
apporter et puis si à l'issue de tout ça
il apparaît que ce vaste rassemblement
doit porter un nouveau nom pourquoi pas
mais si on commence par le nom sans
avoir répondu à l'essentiel je crois
qu'on aura manqué un rendez-vous et je
ne doute pas que Nicolas Sarkozy
avec tous le rassemblement qui va se
retrouver à l'UMP n'est pas pour
priorité d'abord de construire le projet
d'alternance la priorité c'est d'abord
le projet et après l'esthétique
changement de nom changement de tout ça
Nicolas Sarkozy quelqu'un de très motivé
il fait tout en même temps mais oui
pourquoi pas mais pour nous notre temps
Larcher a raison de parler du chômage de
masse tout ça c'est ça les vrais
priorités des Français je pense
qu'effectivement peu de monde en tout
cas tout à l'heure vous nous disiez
effectivement il faut aller vite pour
changer le nom pourquoi pas avant les
élections départementales ça laisse
trois mois trois mois et demi pour le
faire oui tout à fait bah oui mais ça
n'empêche pas de réfléchir aux projets
en même temps ça va permettra de mettre
en place un nouvel équipes et la
nouvelle méthode de fonctionnement aussi
parce que construire un projet ça se
fait avec une méthode ça se fait pas
tout seul dans un coin donc on va voir
est-ce qu'on continue je sais pas les
conventions est-ce qu'on va est-ce qu'il
va avoir des groupes de réflexion est-ce
qu'on va avoir si le comité des premiers
ministres
mal engagés en tout cas merci d'être
venu en plateau Daniel Moselle donc
responsable génération Sarkozy dans les
Yvelines adjoint de Fontenay-le-Fleury
et puis vous reviendrez dans un mois on
fera un bilan très volonté le cadre du 7
8 politique sur cette antenne l'UMP et
l'UDA ils sont en ordre de marche en
tout cas ils abordent la campagne des
départementales sous le signe de l'Union
ce sera le 22 29 mars ils ont présenté
la plupart de leur candidats constitué
pour ces élections de binômes un homme
et une femme l'objectif concourir dans
tous les cantons et surtout l'emporter
une conquête qui passe dans certains
cantons détenus par la gauche par une
implication des mères ainsi sur le
canton de plaisir et qui comprend les
communes de plaisir donc des
Clayes-sous-Bois de benne de
tiverval-grignon l'UMP a mis en première
ligne vous la voyez la mer plaisir
oiseaux Joséphine colemanz berger en
binôme avec un élu de l'UDI Bertrand
Coquard meradju en Clayes-sous-Bois
chargé de la jeunesse des seniors et de
la politique sociale face à eux le
sortant socialiste Jean-Michel bourdon
conseiller municipal d'opposition au
classement
on a des challenges à tenir et puis
plaisir est une ville dynamique et puis
ça fait maintenant deux fois que le
canton échappe au canton de plaisir donc
c'est pas que j'ai la prétention seul de
réussir ça mais enfin je veux dire aussi
cette possibilité de faire un binôme
avec les clés sous bois comme vous le
savez qui aujourd'hui est complètement
intégré à la communauté de communes et
bien paraissait intéressante c'est
vraiment continuer un petit peu la
politique de proximité aujourd'hui je
suis présent sur la ville et
effectivement le département est un
organisme très important des partenariat
avec la Ville qui nous permet d'aller un
petit peu au-delà de ce que la ville
peut faire tout seul avec avec son
budget au niveau effectivement de tout
ce qui est politique de logement tout ce
qui est effectivement infrastructure
routière c'est vraiment important que
l'on puisse au jour d'aujourd'hui y
avoir ce partenariat ce qui m'intéresse
énormément aussi c'est la nouvelle
formule qui associe effectivement
dominos à binôme parité donc ça c'est
très intéressant
biennome aussi d'expérience fort de sa
victoire en mars dernier à Bois-d'Arcy
ville auparavant socialiste le nouveau
maire UMP Philippe Benassaya sera lui
aussi candidat en binôme avec Sonia Bro
première mère adjointe à
Saint-Cyr-l'École l'actuel conseiller
général du canton de Saint-Cyr-l'École
c'est le socialiste Jean-Philippe Mallet
le canton qui compte dorénavant civile
au lieu de 3 avec donc Bois-d'Arcy et
Saint-Cyr-l'École
le mandat de conseiller départemental
vient en complément du mandat de maire
c'est un binôme qui est très intéressant
parce que ça permet de d'allier la ville
au département elle a la rencontre des
gens parler discuter être sur les
marchés faire du porte-à-porte et c'est
vraiment un véritable moment pour
discuter avec les gens c'est pas
simplement une élection un petit peu
voilà
administrative c'est une vraie élection
conseil général avec des vraies
compétences qui touchent les gens au
quotidien ça a été une évidence pour
nous de se regrouper pour ces élections
départementales
Philippe l'a rappelé et je pense que
c'est vraiment important de de le noter
c'est une élection de proximité il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à mobiliser
les départementales c'est la continuité
de la mairie du local et c'est en ce
sens que c'est important je pense que
les gens se mobilisent pour leur
territoire les candidats sont
pratiquement tous connus depuis vendredi
dernier des cantons encore dit réserver
on ne connaîtra qu'en janvier le nom du
binôme candidat sur Rambouillet ou
Christine Boutin sortant de n'a pas pris
de décision sur son avenir sur Montigny
Guyancourt également un canton
actuellement détenu par le maire
socialiste de Guyancourt François de
Lignier et ce dernier lui a annoncé
qu'il brille un nouveau mandat en face
pas encore de nom mais en 2007 on se
souvient que c'est Michel Laugier le
maire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux le
centre est qui est depuis devenu
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération qui s'est donc présenté
à l'époque
UMP UDA qui ont fait des alliances pour
ces élections départementales le
président du conseil général Pierre
bédiène esclut pas d'autres alliances
avec le Parti Chrétien Démocrate mais
aussi avec le Modem le modem dans les
Yvelines 45 élus pas de maire ou de mère
adjoint mais des conseillers municipaux
et qui veulent peser dans le débat
politique le modem des Yvelines va
lancer deux fois par mois des réunions
de débats autour de différents thèmes
locaux départementaux voire nationaux
première réunion la première réunion
s'est tenue la semaine dernière le parti
de François Bayrou a rendu son avis sur
le schéma régional de coopération
intercommunale le préfet de région
propose pour 50 ans en Yvelines une
intercommunalité à 800 000 habitants
incluant notamment Versailles Grand Parc
c'est une proposition à 800.000
habitants qui nous paraît
disproportionnaire c'est ingérable à
moyen et court terme dans la mesure où
il reste il subsiste le département ça
pose aussi des gros problèmes de
cohérence au niveau des universités
puisque ça nous fait un faux
l'université qui est extrêmement étendu
géographiquement alors qu'il y a pas de
moyens de transport donc
ça pose des problèmes mais bon le côté
universitaire est intéressant parce
qu'il est complémentaire malgré tout on
est assez favorable rapprochement de 51
en Yvelines avec Versailles Grand Parc
qui paraît assez cohérent et notamment
très complémentaire au niveau économique
il y a une vraie logique
une première en France les patrons dans
la rue 6000 selon les organisateurs 4500
selon les forces de l'ordre et c'était
en donner rendez-vous à Paris place
Félix Éboué à Paris pour manifester leur
mécontentement le reportage complet est
à retrouver sur notre site internet des
ce soir pour tout comprendre des
revendications nous y reviendrons aussi
dans notre édition de demain et puis eux
aussi étaient mobilisés mais c'était en
fin de semaine dernière les jeunes
agriculteurs d'Île-de-France ouest ils
étaient une trentaine à vouloir mettre
en avant le gâchis foncier en
Île-de-France de terrain laissé en
friche alors qu'il pourrait être
exploité en prenant pour exemple ce site
que vous voyez en photo dans le
Val-d'Oise ils avancent le chiffre de
1000 hectares perdu par an pour
l'agriculture en Île-de-France
dans quelques instants sur tvfils 78 le
7 8 sport avec Anthony Reich c'est la
fin de ce journal je vous retrouve
demain 18h en direct pour la toute
première édition bonne soirée